bienvenue sur LCP bonsoir à tous c'est
ça vous regarde je suis ravie de vous
retrouver au sommaire ce soir on va
parler foot et politique dans notre
grand débat le coup d'envoi du Mondial
c'est dimanche au 14 nous irons à Doua
d'ailleurs rejoindre Vincent Duluc qui
suit l'événement pour à l'équipe Coupe
du Monde de la honte pour beaucoup de
temps les scandales climatiques et
humanitaires sont nombreux de la
boycotter les matchs nous poserons la
question à nos invités dans un instant
sur ce plateau où elle court elle court
Anna et on s'essouffle avec elle coincée
entre son boulot d'éditrice ces trois
filles sa mère en est pas des son mari
qui commence à la tromper le livre dont
on va parler ce soir raconte à merveille
la génération des cinquantenaires pour
qui c'est tout simplement mission
impossible alors comment font les gens
Olivia lamberteri critique littéraire à
elle signe son deuxième roman chez Stock
et on en parlera avec elle dans la
deuxième partie enfin trois affranchis
ce soir trois parties pris Marco pommier
nous raconte le duel Darmanin bernalissi
hier soir dans l'hémicycle vous verrez
c'était le mot de la semaine de la
semiologue Mariette darrigrance et le
mot climat bien sûr et puis Brita
sunberg du spiggle nous dira comment vue
d'Allemagne on regarde la polémique
autour de l'accueil des migrants de
l'océan Viking voilà pour le menu ce
soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et ça y est on y est malgré les torrents
de critique la Coupe du monde de
football adoa commence ce dimanche avec
le match
Qatar Équateur rarement un mondial
n'aura été aussi malaisant comme on dit
aujourd'hui bonsoir Éric Coquerel et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
président de la commission des finances
à l'Assemblée nationale député insoumis
de Seine-Saint-Denis bonsoir Adrien
Gomis ravi de vous accueillir député
Renaissance c'est le parti présidentiel
député de Seine-et-Marne bonsoir Nicolas
Chris Martov bons bienvenue à vous
journaliste à So Foot et auteur de ce
petit livre coup de poing
Qatar le Mondial de la honte c'est aux
éditions Libertalia enfin bonsoir
Vincent du Luc et merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct depuis Doha vous
êtes évidemment journaliste spécialiste
l'un des meilleurs d'ailleurs
spécialistes du football vous êtes vous
êtes journaliste à l'équipe alors je
vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant mais d'abord le regard de Blacko
on ne voilà on ne change pas les règles
les règles une équipe qui gagne j'ai pas
osé alors qui boycott et pourquoi il y
aurait-il un peu d'hypocrisie dans ce
débat si j'ai bien compris le billet de
la côte tout de suite
allez face à tous ces députés fans de
foot assez spécialiste si j'ai bien
compris ce soir si j'ai bien compris
Myriam le spectacle préféré des
habitants de cette planète c'est de
regarder des gars en short courir sur le
gazon il y a aucun spectacle au monde
qui attire plus de spectateurs que la
coupe du monde de foot alors
généralement s'il y a les géo bah non il
y a pas les JO excusez-moi on regarde
les chiffres officiels vous voyez le CIO
Gard revendique 3 milliards de
spectateurs en fait 3 milliards et la
dernière Coupe du Monde qui elle a été
enrichie c'était 3 milliards d'années de
personnes forcément l'idée de parler à 3
milliards de personnes d'un seul coup ça
intéresse beaucoup de gens il y a
beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient
s'adresser d'un seul coup entre un
milliard de personnes vous pensez à qui
au sponsor il est sponsors par exemple
vous savez que les entreprises sont
prêtes à débourser des millions on en
dira combien tout à l'heure pour avoir
leur petit logo associé à la Coupe du
Monde regardez notre Dédé nationale
quand il s'exprime c'est bourré de
sponsors derrière il y a 25 sponsors
pour l'équipe de France 14 internation
niveau des Chinois des Allemands des
Japonais tout le monde y est mais bon si
on est un petit peu malin on peut quand
même profiter de la caisse de résonance
de la Coupe du monde sans dépenser un
sou regarde c'est ce que font les
politiques par exemple ils profitent de
la Coupe du monde pour mettre en avant
leurs idées les mères écologistes de
certaines villes de France vous l'avez
vu en position en interdisant les écrans
géants parfois on s'interroge un peu sur
la sincérité des prises de position on
pense line avec dalgo le PSG c'est quand
même le Qatar quand elle avec le kata
elles sont en très bien avec le Qatar
elle le disait même à la radio écoutez
ce que je peux dire sur Paris et sur la
relation que l'on a avec avec le PSG
avec le patron du PSG et bien c'est une
relation extrêmement d'abord positive
très très forte voilà et de son côté
Emmanuel Macron a dit il y a deux jours
qu'il ne fallait pas politiqueiser le
sport
mais vous confondez tout vous confondez
le sport et la politique alors que ça
n'a rien à voir donc le président lui
qu'est-ce qu'il fait évidemment il bote
en touche comme on dit plutôt au rugby
en disant non surtout pas de polémique
on va pas se fâcher avec le Qatar alors
évidemment quand on est plus
responsabilité là ça devient plus facile
de faire prendre des positions
courageuses on pense à François Hollande
qui lui a dit nettement moi si j'étais
encore Président je fais de Sarkozy en
fait c'est Hollande je n'irai pas au
Qatar moins facile à une amende parce
qu'on se souvient bien que François
Hollande il y allait au Qatar quand il
fallait vendre des armes et que les
droits de l'homme ça ne le souciait pas
plus que ça à l'époque on a tous noté de
contradiction regardez la Norvège par
exemple voilà un pays exemplaire
l'équipe de Norvège elle elle a mis les
pieds dans le plat elle a dit les droits
de l'homme il faut faire quelque chose
contre bon il y a juste un truc c'est
que il y a les géodes d'hiver qui
étaient à Pékin en 2022 et là la Norvège
elle a pas bricoté pour les droits de
l'homme mais pourquoi pas on regarde le
classement c'est les rois des sports
d'hiver les Norvégiens donc ils avaient
tellement de médailles en or qui n'ont
pas voulu effectivement
boycotter la Chine
énormément de raisons de ce côté-là
d'ailleurs c'est justement la Coupe du
monde c'était l'occasion d'en parler la
presse on a beaucoup parlé le monde a
beaucoup fait des pages sur la
catastrophe climatique représente cette
Coupe du Monde on a vu dans les échos de
la presse économique aussi les
conséquences en France avec cette
esclavage moderne dont on accuse les
catering mais le truc c'est est-ce qu'il
faut pour autant boycotter la Coupe du
monde alors ce qui est frappant c'est
que les très grandes ONG elle ne
boycotent pas par exemple amnestyle
internationale une boycote pas le catin
regardez il préfère faire pression sur
le Qatar plutôt que de boycotter
Greenpeace c'est pareil c'est référence
dans le domaine de l'écologie là je
voulais pas le texte enfin ils disent
pas qu'il fait le bon côté au contraire
rester dans votre canapé ne prenez pas
l'avion regardez tranquillement dans
votre canapé la Coupe du Monde c'est la
consigne de Greenpeace est-ce que vous
allez faire aussi regardez les matchs
moi j'ai mauvaise conscience si vous
voulez je serai tenté de regarder je
sais pas je regarderai coquerelles j'ai
pas trop envie mais il y a quand même
Olivier Véran qui m'a donné une bonne
excuse pour me motoriser à regarder ce
que de toute façon c'est trop tard on
écoute
ce qui était décidé il y a 10 ans par la
une centaine de pays dans le monde qui a
été accompagnée pendant 10 ans c'est
compliqué à quelques semaines du début
de dire tout d'un coup en fait il faut
pas le faire ma conviction c'est que si
on devait prendre telle décision
aujourd'hui on ne donnerait pas la Coupe
du Monde de Qatar mais bien sûr on a
tous retenus la leçon ça ne recommencera
pas je pose juste une question est-ce
que vous savez qui organise les jeux
divers asiatiques en 2029
qui merci en tout cas je voulais
commencer par Vincent du Luc et qui est
qui est sur place parce que j'aimerais
savoir d'ailleurs si sur place déjà il y
a quelque chose d'une perception d'un
malaise Vincent alors dites-nous déjà ce
que vous avez vu et est-ce qu'il y a
matière à être choquée déjà avant même
que que les matchs ne commencent
non parce que de toute façon c'est une
coupe du monde qui se sous ces aspects
là étaient largement documentés et
longuement ces derniers mois ça n'a la
semaine non parce que de toute façon
la presse sportive qu'on pourrait
accuser de faire la politique de
l'autruche à au fur et à mesure que
l'événement savon c'est en fait a été la
première à dénoncer l'absurdité de soi
il y a 10 ans simplement à l'époque
c'était pas un débat public qui
n'intéresse absolument personne et en
fait pour l'instant on voit pas grand
chose parce qu'il y a pas grand monde
qui est arrivé à part ces supporters
indiens qui sont supportés à peu près
tous les pays et qu'il faut se mettre de
l'ambiance à l'arrivée des stades tout
semble un peu artificiel en fait c'est
un moment un peu suspendu pas seulement
parce que la Coupe du monde ne commence
que dimanche parce qu'on continue à en
fait on se demande quand on croise de a
de haut en bas et et de gauche à droite
et ça prend pas de sens que ça comment
comment cette ville va pouvoir
accueillir les supporters de 32 équipes
à partir de lundi on se dit que c'est
absolument impossible que ni les restos
ni les métros ni les transports ni les
routes on va être capable d'amortir ça
c'est plutôt en ce moment c'est cette
question là que je me pose j'ai
l'impression que c'est voilà que c'est
que c'est pas faux c'est presque un
jouable et c'est vraiment une c'est un
vrai point d'interrogation pourtant les
infrastructures elles sont elles sont là
et bien là les stades sont là on a même
expliqué que parce que c'est un petit
pays bah les supporters serait souvent
logés dans des hôtels dans les pays d'à
côté et prendront l'avion pour pour
venir ce qui peut paraître là encore une
forme d'hérésie mais mais quoi c'est il
y aura il y aura du monde il y aura de
l'audience ils seront remplies ces
stades et ça va être dur d'ailleurs de
recevoir les les supporters dans la vie
je reviens vers vous Vincent parce que
vous nous avez dit que vous pouvez
rester un moment avec nous comment
comment on pourrait qualifier ce Mondial
vous Nicolas christmaster vous avez pris
parti c'est très clairement pour vous le
Mondial de la honte pourquoi qu'il avait
la raison principale c'est quoi c'est le
riz climatique c'est c'est la mort des
ouvriers sur les chantiers c'est parce
que il y a une agglomération toutes les
problématiques autour du football
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut bien comprendre
que c'est le football qui est la cause
de tout ce qu'on des questions qu'on se
pose c'est le football qui a provoqué
une accélération énorme puisqu'ils ont
eu la Coupe du Monde de leur projet de
développement économique ils ont un
budget de 200 milliards et c'est pas
parce que la Coupe du Monde vaut 200
milliards parce que le Qatar se
reconstruit il s'est reconstruit
entièrement autour de cette Coupe du
Monde c'est la question climatique qui a
paru assez récemment faut savoir qu'on
pour le coup ça fait un an Maxime ou
deux ans qu'on en entend parler à part
quelques ONG par contre les droits
humains moi j'ai été au cas moi j'étais
au Népal en 2014 il y avait déjà une
série d'articles dans la presse
internationale et des ONG des syndicats
qui se mobilisaient la CGT à mener sa
première campagne en 2014 et 751 morts
depuis 2010
et 300 un peu moins de 350 pour les
autorités
malheureusement mourir en revenant au
pays parce qu'ils ont ils leur santé ont
été abîmés parce qu'ils ont en BU de le
dos des sénéiser qui est très mauvaise
pour et qui vont dans des après retour
de chez eux il y a pas système de santé
et c'est je pense que c'est que le début
on ne saura jamais chiffres exact mais
il est bien plus important à mon avis
que celui-là c'est cette honte là et
puis un moment c'est aussi la question
de la révélé qu'est-ce que une coupe du
monde comment on décide de l'attribuer
on voit bien comment fonctionne un FIFA
et c'est quand même assez surprenant
cela dit moi je partage que ce qu'a dit
Vincent du Luc la presse sportive dès
l'attribution en 2010 moi j'ai commencé
déjà à regarder kata parce qu'il a tué
des droits TD qu'il était dans cette
grande guerre du soft power avec
l'Arabie Saoudite mais si on a beaucoup
parlé
la question du boycott quand on est
journaliste sportif
elle se pose pas où elle se pose j'ai
jamais parce que aucun État n'allait
boycotter un tel partenaire économique
j'ai jamais trouvé
le travail c'est quand même de couvrir
arrêter les choses quand on va mes
confrères qui vont couvrir d'une manière
bien courageuse les guerres ou des
conflits comme en Ukraine il ne valide
rien juste il faut on est là pour
traiter et relater ce qui va se passer
moi j'ai confiance en effet que la
presse qui est qui est au Qatar et nous
annonce sportive va aussi regarder de
tous les d'un côté non non le boycott
mais j'ai jamais cru s'il y a jamais été
question de boycott tu sais c'est
hallucinant pour moi c'est une vraie
diversion par rapport à ce qui était les
vrais enjeux qui se posaient autour de
cette coupe du monde donc on boy code
pas le Mondial de la honte personne même
si c'est le Mondial de la honte personne
ne boycott pas
c'est un cauchemar pour vous ce mondial
comme vous voyez des choses
il y a tant de choses qui sont un
cauchemar sur la planète en tout cas
c'est une faute et un non sens à la fois
morale environnemental
social et sportif j'ai juste sportif
parce qu'on l'oublie souvent c'est un
non-sens de jouer en pleine saison une
coupe du monde ça explique aussi très
certainement le nombre de blessés dans
les équipes qui arrivent bon donc tout
ça mis bout à bout on se demande alors
maintenant on le sait parce que je
disais moral parce que manifestement la
France d'après ce qu'on comprend a joué
un rôle puisqu'il y a une enquête
actuellement du du parquet financier sur
l'attribution de cette et pas un rôle
pas un rôle très propre
qui est ouverte et plusieurs articles de
presse moi je suis d'accord le Buck cut
sportif toute façon on savait que
c'était impossible par contre le minimum
cette décision elle a été prise elle a
été prise maintenant il y a plus de 10
ans il faut avancer il a pas raison de
dire maintenant on de politiser ce
Mondial il est là
tout est prof de ce type au niveau
international depuis très longtemps même
avant 36 les Jeux de Berlin mais je
pourrais le citer et politique on sait
bien
même même Macron est un des premiers à
utiliser le sport à des fins politiques
on peut pas dire ça et donc à partir de
là justement moi je pense que si il dit
Simon Macron dit c'est une décision qui
a été prise sous-entendu bien avant moi
et de toute façon maintenant on est
engagé certes mais lui il a le choix
pour rendre de décider d'aller ou pas
dans cette Coupe du monde si la France
arrive en demi-finale j'espère qu'il
n'ira pas exigence hérésie climatique
drame humain quand même le nombre de
morts est énorme ça fait froid dans le
dos et quand on regarde aussi la
question des LGBT Hugo Lloris qui refuse
de porter le brassard arc-en-ciel alors
que d'autres sélections ont décidé de le
faire comment vous réagissez bien
évidemment on est tous premièrement
sensibiliser à la situation dramatique
qu'on connu les travailleurs c'est une
évidence je vais vous surprendre
toutefois et je vais en venir aux propos
que je souhaite tenir je vais vous citer
un homme politique c'est pas souvent que
que je le fais mais avec lequel je suis
entièrement d'accord c'était il y a 13
ans un certain sénateur qui disait je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le boycott des
Jeux Olympiques de Pékin
pour moi le boycot des jeux est une
agression injustifiée à insultante
contre le peuple chinois si l'on voulait
mettre en cause le régime de Pékin il
fallait le faire au moment du choix de
Pékin pour les jeux je vais faire
plaisir au président Coquerel c'est une
phrase de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui l'a
tenu il y a 13 ans en réalité on le voit
aujourd'hui le boycott ça ne me semble
pas être une bonne idée j'écoute je me
suis beaucoup informé sur le sujet on a
eu la chance au sein de la commission
des affaires étrangères mercredi matin
d'avoir une table ronde très
intéressante notamment avec Pascal
Boniface qui est le directeur de l'iris
de l'Institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques on voit
aujourd'hui que plusieurs ONG c'était
dit précédemment comme Amnesty
International comme Human Right Watch
disent en réalité le boycott c'est pas
véritablement le levier le plus
intéressant pour faire évoluer les
droits humains au Qatar
bien évidemment c'est pas assez on est
tout à fait d'accord autour de la de
cette table pour pour se dire ça ça ne
va pas assez loin mais on a eu la kafala
qui est ce système assez particulier
vous le savez de contrôle des
travailleurs étrangers par les catarys
qui a été suspendu il y a un salaire
minimum très faible trop faible on est
bien d'accord qui a été instauré avant
je pense que le sport et l'organisation
le fait qu'on est aujourd'hui un coup de
projecteur sur le Qatar quoi qu'on pense
de l'opportunité et vous le disiez
précédemment ça va obliger en effet je
pense le Qatar a bougé sur un certain
nombre de points c'est déjà ce qui est
fait quand j'entends un certain nombre
minimal sur Non mais il y a des avancées
on pense qu'il y a 2 % des gens qui sont
concernés par ce que je vous dis
monsieur le Président je pense qu'il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin on est
d'accord sur ce point il y a pas de
sujet mais je pense que le boycott est
une fausse bonne idée d'ailleurs c'est
la première fois je précise ça que arabe
organisent une coupe du monde c'est ce
que dit aussi les Qataris il s'insurgent
et il dénonce le Cathar machine en
disant il y a un peu d'islamophobie
derrière tout ça vous êtes d'accord avec
faux
dans tous les cas il faut pas être dans
une vision anachronique des choses il y
a 10 ans ce sont les fédérations
sportives qui décident de l'attribution
au Qatar de cette Coupe du Monde ok
c'est pas les États qui se prononcent
contrairement à ce que je peux entendre
sur le terrain c'est pas les États qui
pour vous qui se prononcent n'aurait pas
dû prendre cette décision mais à vrai
dire c'est pas
français qui doit avoir non moi je pense
que regretter il y a la décision de la
FIFA ils avaient je n'ai pas regretté ou
pas je ne répondrai pas à cette question
toutefois toutefois je pense que des
efforts à l'époque ont été faits et ça a
été un petit peu anticipé puisque
regardez la Coupe du Monde et le
président Coquerel le disait
précédemment a lieu en novembre et
décembre du fait notamment du climat un
peu moins
caniculaire que en plein été on savait
qu'il y allait avoir un certain nombre
d'implication directe le fait
d'organiser ce Mondial et dans le même
temps en 2010 on n'avait pas la question
climatique qui prenait autant
d'importance dans nos débats c'est une
réalité donc l'époque a changé l'époque
a changé maintenant j'ouvre une autre
question je réponds pas à votre question
et j'en ouvre une autre
la question va se poser dans quatre ans
dans 4 ans on a une coupe du monde qui
va être organisée à cheval entre trois
pays trois pays pour deux d'entre eux
particulièrement grand étendu les
États-Unis le Canada et le Mexique qui
aussi étendu il va y avoir oui qui est
moins étendu peut-être que les
États-Unis vous avez raison
vont se poser sur notamment la question
la question climatique sur la question
climatique et les déplacements parce
qu'il y a un certain nombre de
d'articles qui relaient justement à la
question des déplacements nombreux la
question va se poser
ça sera pas la même chose
je suis bien d'accord vous avez compris
mon propos je pense que le fait de
mettre les projecteurs sur un pays ça
peut faire avancer les droits même si ça
va pas assez loin Vincent du Luc vous
voyez les choses comme ça
au
fondateurs sur un pays qui doit tout
prouver et qui est coupable on peut le
dire avec le traitement de ces
travailleurs il ne peut qu'avancer
parce que la pression internationale a
fonctionné c'est-à-dire que jamais un
pays organisateur du Coupe du monde aux
Jeux Olympiques nouvelle payer aussi
cher en termes d'image mondiale
c'est-à-dire que là pour le coup le soft
power il a il en prend vraiment un bon
coup et c'est le
Qatar pour moi a déjà perdu un peu
j'imagine pas que la Coupe du monde lui
permet d'être un vainqueur incontestable
après sur d'autres dossiers il faut être
un peu précis sur le sur le sur le sur
le problème climatique évidemment qu'il
y a un problème climatique mais il y
aura pas de climatisation dans les
stades par exemple c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut voilà il faut il faut juste
être précis je pense que le bilan à
terme dans les stades la catastrophiques
parce qu'il y aura il y aura de la
climatisation pendant les années à venir
et tout le temps au Qatar mais pendant
cette Coupe du Monde nature permettront
de se passer de la climatisation c'est
bien ça
on sait qu'en décembre il va faire entre
15 et 25 degrés il fera moins chaud que
dans que dans la plupart des coupes du
monde et des euros qui qui se déroulent
endettés donc ça ça effectivement c'est
pas
on se demande qui va remplir des stades
principalement qui des asiatiques les
pays voisins du Qatar
il y aura beaucoup quand même de
supporters
[Musique]
qu'on regarde le Qatar il faut imaginer
que d'autres d'autres pays du monde ont
pas tout à fait la même vision du Qatar
et d'autres pays du monde vont se faire
une fête et il y a quand même 32 pays
qualifiés il y a que 13 européens donc
il va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
supporters qui qui vont venir là et
d'une manière générale au premier tour
les stades sont jamais plaints ils le
sont après je suis sûr qu'ils le seront
au Qatar soit parce qu'ils le seront par
des vrais supporters soit parce qu'ils
sont remplis de faux supporters
là-dessus j'ai aucun doute sur les
ressources du pays organisateur bon
alors je vous donne la parole dans un
tout petit instant mais je vais vous
montrer quand même que la question du
boycott elle est quand même largement
partagée et qu'à voir les sondages les
Français sont majorés de paiement
insatisfaits d'attribution du Mondial à
ce pays il y a certains bars à la fois
en France mais aussi dans d'autres pays
d'Europe comme l'Allemagne qui ont
décidé d'organiser très clairement à
boycott avec d'autres alternatives au
bistrot star reportage d'Hélène
Bonduelle regardez
c'était il y a quatre ans devant ses
écrans géants 1500 personnes vibraient
pour l'équipe de France en pleine Coupe
du Monde on a vraiment vécu une fête
très populaire très
sympathique bon enfant avec des
générations qui se croisaient des types
de publics différents et c'est ça qu'on
n'aura pas cette année on peut pas
diffuser un match quand on sait qu'il y
a plus près de 6000 personnes qui ont
100 morts sur les chantiers que les
droits des travailleurs ne sont pas
respectés que l'environnement c'est
absolument débile d'avoir des stats qui
serviront une fois deux fois on fait de
leçons à personne on se sent pas à
l'aise avec ça donc on le fait pas
l'établissement a fait voter ses équipes
et a décidé de ne pas retransmettre la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar à la place une
contreprogrammation les soirs de match
tournoi de foot de baby-foot mais aussi
des conférences et même une soirée
Parlement populaire sur le thème du
sport éthique donc on aura des experts
on aura des pros Coupe du Monde des anti
Coupe du Monde au Qatar on aura aussi
des gens qui ont des solutions à
apporter et puis
le citoyen le public qui viendra aussi
s'exprimer et on va essayer de sortir
une proposition de loi sur ces sujets
alors entrer un match de foot et une
soirée débat et les clients devront
faire un choix moi le premier je crois
que alors que pourtant j'aime regarder
le football je pense que j'ai moins
suivre pour ces raisons là aussi
j'irai le voir des amis de toute façon
et puis on passera aussi un bon moment
ensemble un défaut d'avoir un boycott de
la France on va dire c'est pas mal qui
est des lieux qui prennent cette
responsabilité et qui disent aussi on
offrira pas une audience supplémentaire
à quelque chose qu'on cautionne pas ce
site ramenait la coupe à la raison
recense d’ailleurs les barres français
qui proposeront des alternatives les
soirs de match
en Allemagne ce barberlinois affiche lui
aussi clairement la couleur boycott
cathares dans un pays friand de foot et
quatre fois champion du monde se
responsable assume son choix aucune
retransmission
le Qatar utilise la Coupe du monde pour
améliorer sa réputation et se présenter
sur la scène internationale différemment
de ce qu'il est en réalité
nous nous attendons à une baisse de
notre chiffre d'affaires et de nos
profits mais nous ne pensons pas que
cela nous conduira à la faillite
[Musique]
et à deux jours de l'ouverture de la
Coupe du Monde l'effet boycott semble
prendre de l'ampleur en France près d'un
amateur de foot sur 4 affirme qu'il ne
regardera aucun match
vous allez regarder vous les bleus
j'ai dit je pensais que le Buck cut
c'était trop tard et que on pouvait pas
le faire mais sur cette idée que à mon
avis totalement soi naïve soit quand je
pense que c'est de la naïveté pour vous
je vais être gentil soit hypocrite qui
consiste à dire les choses vont changer
après ça peut accélérer je ne connais
pas un seul exemple
les prosportives JO ou Coupe du Monde
organisant dans un pays posant des
problèmes sur les questions des droits
de l'homme entre autres qui est fait en
sorte que le pays change après pas plus
la Chine de 2008 pas plus l'Allemagne de
36 pas plus par exemple la Coupe du
Monde au Mexique en 1970 si c'était
ouvert
donc ça ça c'est pas vrai voilà que les
organisations Amnesty et autres se
disent bon bah maintenant c'est fait
c'est fait on peut essayer de de faire
en sorte que ça progresse elles ont
raison de le faire mais n'ayons pas
naïvité de penser que ça va évoluer
si vous voulez parce que tout à l'heure
j'ai entendu beaucoup de fonds concrets
l'instauration d'un salaire minimum vous
pouvez
avancées
il y a pas de loi d'altérations
apparemment des gens concernés et on va
voir ce qui se passe je vous ai dit ça
voilà
en terme de pratique et d'ailleurs des
pratiques qui continuent à être bizarres
il suffit de regarder du côté du
Paris-Saint-Germain manifestement de de
d'espionnage et autres qui peuvent être
faites pour essayer d'obtenir
les JO bon deuxièmement je ne crois pas
que ça soit juste les instances
sportives vu l'ampleur et l'importance
maintenant de de d'épreuve de ce type
qui sont décisionnaires et là encore je
reviens à ce qui est en train de se
passer les enquêtes pour corruption
passive quand même voilà donc
troisièmement est-ce que je regarderai
là et toutes les contradictions je la
mets c'est à dire que pour moi et
pourtant vous allez regarder je pense
que je vais regarder quelques matchs
mais je peux vous dire une chose
notamment les matchs de l'équipe de
France je vous donne chaud c'est que et
d'une je me pose encore la question
quand on a apprend pas à expliquer que
il refusait à le faire et de
contrairement à ce qui peut se passer
sur l'autre je suis incapable de donner
aujourd'hui le calendrier de l'épreuve
et de vous donner les rendez-vous parce
que ça peut pas être une fête voilà
c'est peut-être des matchs qu'on peut
regarder parce que moi j'admets mon
amour le fait que j'adore le foot et que
de pas voir pas avoir Benzema très
profondément mais ça ne peut pas être
une fête cette coupe du monde ça s'il
est pas possible Nicolas
on pose la question avec Éric Coquerel
est-ce que c'est aux instances sportives
et à la FIFA en particulier de décider
il y a une enquête du PNF qui a été
ouverte on a vu des papiers dans le
monde dans Mediapart autour d'un
déjeuner à l'Elysée le 23 novembre 2010
avec le président Nicolas Sarkozy des
dignitaires de cathari Michel Platini
qui était patron de l'UEFA à l'époque et
qui était d'ailleurs un membre influent
du comité exécutif de la Fifa qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous pensez au fond
déjà de ce qu'on sait de l'ATT et des
papiers qui sortent avec cette enquête
et est-ce qu'il faut changer les règles
la FIFA c'est elle qui donne qui
attribue effectivement les coupe du
monde comme le SIO d'ici de qui va
recevoir les Jeux Olympiques à l'époque
c'était le bureau aujourd'hui dans la
FIFA c'est le bureau de la FIFA qui
avait voté l'attribution en Qatar
aujourd'hui c'est l'ensemble des
fédérations qui votent ils ont changé
c'est ils ont juste changé ce modèle
mais pour revenir au cas où vous citez
ben non on a le pour le coup la France a
joué un rôle très important dans
l'attribution de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar l'État français Nicolas Sarkozy en
tant que président de la République est
intervenu parce qu'on sait précisément
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il a organisé un
dîner qui voulait faire obtenir de
Michel platine dont on pensait qu'il
était plutôt favorable à une candidature
américaine à l'époque grande favorite
alors ce que dit Michel Platini c'est
quand il agit jamais demandé on lui a
jamais dit fais un on a déjà midi en
tant que Français tu dois changer ton
vote c'est l'intérêt national mais il a
reconnu dans un interview on m'a fait
comprendre clairement parce que j'ai
bien vu qu'il était assise dîner ce
qu'on attendait de moi et par le plus
grand des hasards par la suite hein il a
changé d'avis le classique donc le Qatar
a racheté le PSG a un ami de Nicolas
marque aussi monsieur Bazin investi dans
son groupe Accor et la France a pu mener
à bien son savant de Rafale je sais que
c'est effectivement monsieur woodland
qui l'a signé à Doha et pour terminer
les intérêts de la France que il y
aurait une pression
Qatar le Qatar est devenu un sous
Monsieur Nicolas Sarkozy mais c'était
directement au préalable et ça a été par
la suite un partenaire économique très
important de notre pays mais au-delà de
ça et aujourd'hui encore et les groupes
de BTP français ont énormément de
contrats il y a 6000 expatriés français
qui vivent au Qatar qui travaillent
là-bas et puis c'est pas des employés
n'est pas des ils ont pas ils sont pas
soumis à ces conditions là donc voilà il
y a énormément il y a des enjeux
extrêmement importants une attribution
de coupe du monde ça n'est jamais que la
FIFA qui décide pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que il faut trouver la
FIFA à deux ambitions dans son dans son
projet fondamental de développement du
football que la Coupe du monde soit la
plus belle la plus prestigieuse avec les
plus beaux installations et entre la pub
au voyante donc le Qatar est arrivé il
savait que c'est un acteur économique
extrêmement riche et qu'il avait offrir
tout ça d'autres pays arabes avaient
comme le Maroc en une coupe du monde
bizarrement on aura pas donné donc c'est
pas la question d'islamophobie qui ou de
ces questions là qui joue et
deuxièmement pour la FIFA c'est un état
stable
et donc un état stable c'est quoi c'est
où des démocraties de type France
États-Unis ou alors on a pas de l'avenir
ou le Qatar qui offre et comme la très
bien expliqué Jérôme Val qui était à
l'époque secrétaire général de la FIFA
il dictature c'est pas si embêtant
mais tout va bien se passer aussi dans
une dictature comme le Qatar que si on
organise aux États-Unis ensuite 500 du
lieu que vous vouliez réagir à cette
question de l'attribution au Qatar
oui un peu sur tous les points d'abord
pour dire que effectivement que Michel
Platini a voté pour le Qatar sur le sous
le on va dire la pression de Nicolas
Sarkozy mais que son vote un lien
changer s'il avait voté pour le pour les
pour les pour les États-Unis le Qatar
aurait quand même gagné 13 fois à 9 et
d'autre part je suis assez agacé pour
rester resté nuancé par l'hypocrisie
quand même un vrai semblable de la de la
classe politique de plusieurs bords qui
qui condamne le Qatar a juste titre mais
qui s'empêche jamais de s'installer en
corbeille au Parc des Princes pour
suivre le PSG et juste dire une petite
anecdote c'est qu'ici dans mon hôtel
juste en face il y a le musée national
du Qatar qui a été construit par Jean
Nouvel avec exactement les mêmes
esclaves que ceux qui ne construit le
stade et que j'ai jamais entendu que ça
dérange la société française de manière
générale si moi ça me dérange moi ça me
dérange et je vais pas voir du PSG voilà
non mais je vous le dis donc c'est pas
l'ensemble de la classe politique
c'est vrai que le Qatar on parle du soft
power il y a évidemment beaucoup
d'investissements principalement dans le
sport mais pas seulement beaucoup
d'acquisitions d'hôtels de l'immobilier
etc il y a un agenda politique aussi du
Qatar vis-à-vis des pays européens
agenda islamique ou pas avant ce que je
peux vous dire dans tous les cas c'est
qu'avant l'attribution de la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar on entendait beaucoup
moins parler de ce pays ça c'est une
évidence donc ça a été un coup de
projecteur incroyable je partage tout à
fait les propos qui ont été tenus
précédemment il faut sortir de cette
hypocrisie quand on entend la mère de
Paris nid d'algo nous expliquer il y a
quelques temps qu'elle entretient de
parfaite relations avec le Qatar puis
aujourd'hui dire en plein de mois
novembre moins de novembre qu'elle ne
mettra pas d'écran géants sur sur la
place de l'hôtel de ville c'est
complètement hypocrite la question c'est
pourquoi boycotter dans ce cas là
l'organisation de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar dans ce cas là il faut tout
boycotter et tout boycotter c'est le
métro qui est fait notamment par des
entreprises françaises par ce que vous
disiez précédemment l'ensemble
des activités économiques et des
partenariats économiques qui peuvent qui
peuvent exister ma question c'est je
crois qu'on a bien compris qu'il y avait
des interdépendants économiques et des
intérêts des deux côtés est-ce qu'il y a
autre chose est-ce qu'il y a un agenda
politique beaucoup de politiques disent
que le Qatar finance des mosquées
finances des certains associations
est-ce que cet agenda elle existe on
parle des Frères musulmans ou les choses
ont changé ou n'existent pas c'est en
tout cas un partenaire diplomatique pour
parler à des personnes qui ont qui on a
pas envie qui on a pas eu ça directement
le Hezbollah l'Iran donc eux ils le font
là dans la crise dans l'évacuation de en
Afghanistan ils étaient très importants
c'est là c'est de la réal politique
c'est à dire qu'à un moment où vous avez
besoin d'interlocuteurs qui sont
capables de serrer des mains que vous
avez pas envie forcément de toucher ce
qui est aussi une forme d'hypocrisie
après sur cette question d'agenda
d'investissement de du Qatar dans
d'autres sperme moi je veux pas
m'avancer
pour la on voit bien
apparemment à cause de ça comme celui
ci-jupe qu'est-ce que veut faire le
Qatar il veut exister montrer qu'il est
important et qu'il a et qu'il veut
survivre à la fin de l'hydrocarbure
parce que leur crise et leur angoisses à
tous ces pays du Golfe c'est ce qui
s'est passé au Koweït on veut plus
revenir mais ça se reproduit qu'il y a
une puissance régionale qui nous attaque
venez nous défendre et vous nous direz
une défense parce qu'on pèse
économiquement qu'on était parti voilà
c'est la pétrole survivre il nous reste
quelques petites minutes pour parler de
sport pour terminer l'hypocrisie parce
que on sait bien un des une des
questions aujourd'hui fondamentales
au-delà c'est les réserves de gaz
naturel liquéfier que le cataracte qui
sont les plus important au monde total
vient de signer un contrat extrêmement
important donc moi je crois que qui à un
moment donné vous ayez pour des raisons
géostratégiques ou des raisons
énergétiques ou des raisons économiques
certains liens avec des pays avec qui
par ailleurs que vous condamnez au
niveau du régime politique c'est une
chose d'accord c'est une chose par
exemple actuellement il y a la question
de la diversification
de de l'origine du du gaz bon mais c'est
une autre de participer au fait de
ripoliner le pays c'est-à-dire de lui
donner une une stature et une image que
que donne la Coupe du monde et de
contribuer à ça et pour moi je pense que
là ça c'est un élément qu'il fallait
éviter de seconde je voudrais quand même
aller voir Vincent dullik et Nicolas
Chris Markov pour avoir leur expertises
d'abord il y a une question elle est à
la Une de l'équipe aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce que Karim Benzema sera d'attaque
pour jouer mardi on sait qu'il se remet
d'une petite blessure enfin d'une
blessure quand même importante est-ce
qu'il est il est pas aux entraînements
qu'est-ce que vous savez
il est à l'entraînement hier mais il est
la participé quelle version
individualisée de l'entraînement je
pense qu'il prendra pas de risque ça
fait depuis un mois il a seulement joué
une demi-heure en Ligue des Champions
contre celtique donc je pense qu'il
prendra pas de risque et qui sera
seulement contre l'Australie il y a
d'autres solutions offensives dans
l'idéal la Coupe du Monde sera longue et
c'est un risque qu'il faut pas prendre
et est-ce qu'on a malgré une équipe si
d'après Jean-Pierre Montanet qui connaît
bien mieux que moi le foot et c'est le
rédacteur en chef de cette émission une
équipe qui est pas terrible parce
qu'elle a pas de milieu de terrain très
expérimenté est-ce qu'on a quand même
des chances d'aller loin dans la
compétition voir de gagner
Jean-Pierre avec qui j'ai repenté les
stades que effectivement bien le foot et
il a raison je pense qu'on a un milieu
de terrain de un des plus faibles depuis
très longtemps mais pas forcément un des
plus faibles en fait un des plus mal
connues et on peut espérer que la
compétition le
révèle ces joueurs là c'est pas certain
tout le socle il manquera beaucoup du
socle défensif qu'elle était à la base
du titre de champion du monde il y a 4
ans et on sait très bien qu'une Coupe du
Monde ou un championnat d'Europe ne se
gagne rarement sur l'attaque mais plutôt
sur la défense et la question est le
doute est plutôt dans ce domaine merci
beaucoup Vincent Duluc de nous avoir
accordé votre temps précieux depuis Doha
un petit pronostic je me tourne quand
même vers l'expert que vous êtes on a pu
le temps pour vous deux dites nous les
Bleus
rapidement vraiment parce que le temps
qui qui nous est à partir des PC déjà
j'avoue j'ai aucune appétence pour ce
qui va se passer pendant cette coupe du
monde mais le style de jeu de Deschamps
m'a jamais fait rêver en équipe de
France je sais que c'est très dur à dire
aujourd'hui parce que mais moi depuis
moi je suis encore des années 80 donc
voilà j'espère fortement que Benzema
sera pas forfait parce que si on a la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et qu'en plus on
voit pas je Benzema jouer ça me posera
toutes nos chances on a toutes nos
chances on y croit alors merci merci à
tous Nicolas Chris Martov cata lemondial
de la honte c'est aux éditions
Libertalia Vincent Duluc je tenais
absolument à montrer ce magnifique
dictionnaire amoureux de la Coupe du
monde qui vient tout juste de sortir
chez plomb c'est passionnant merci à
vous messieurs on va s'arrêter à présent
sur Anna elle court Anna toute la
journée sans même un chapitre pour
reprendre son souffle elle est coincée
entre son boulot d'éditrice ces trois
filles sa mère en est pas des son mari
beaucoup se reconnaîtront dans le livre
qui raconte à merveille la génération
des cinquantenaires pour elle s’émission
impossible alors comment font les gens
Olivia Lamberterie ce deuxième livre là
c'est un roman chez Stock on l'accueille
juste après l'invitation qui lui est
adressée ce soir par Elsa bonagara
Olivia de Lamberterie c'est pour se
poser ensemble cette question comment
font les gens comment vivre dans un
monde où les journées ne durent que 24
heures et où il faut gérer son travail
ses amis sa famille comment être heureux
dans un monde où on ne parle que de
guerre ou de réchauffement climatique
Olivia de Lamberterie vous êtes critique
littéraire rédactrice en chef adjointe
du magazine Elle en 2018 vous
franchissez le Rubicon et signez votre
premier livre avec toutes mes sympathies
aujourd'hui dans comment font les gens
vous vous demandez surtout comment font
les femmes pour arriver à faire tout à
cocher toutes les cases à s'occuper de
leurs enfants à faire leur métier le
mieux possible je voulais essayer de
raconter la vie des femmes mais en même
temps le raconter totalement de
l'intérieur c'est donc dans la peau
d'Anna que vous vous glissez 53 ans
coincé entre deux générations sa mère a
géré féministe des années 70 qui perd la
tête et ses trois filles des jeunes
filles d'aujourd'hui opposition plus
radicales ajoutez à cela un travail
prenant et un mari volage et votre
héroïne n'a qu'un rêve une heure rien
que pour elle la charge mentale une
notion récente pour une réalité plus
ancienne regardée ce reportage des
années 70 parce que chaque jour à 5h30
Maggie quitte son travail analyste dans
un centre d'informatique de l'éducation
nationale sa journée est loin d'être
terminée un quart d'heure de vélomoteur
la sépare de son appartement de
Montrouge pendant le trajet elle a le
temps de récapituler ce qu'il attend à
son retour les cours sont pour le dîner
la cuisine pour 4 vous brossez le
portrait de celle veulent tout être à la
fois la mer la fille la menthe l'ami et
pour cela vous l'écrivez courir c'est la
profession des femmes quel que soit leur
métier la vie comme une course une
course de fond et aussi une course
contre la montre
bonsoir Olivia Lamberterie bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être là c'est vrai
qu'elle respire pas beaucoup Anna elle
court toute la journée elle donnerait
n'importe quoi pour un peu plus de temps
une heure aller tous les deux jours si
c'était possible comment font les gens
c'est de ce titre c'est rare d'ailleurs
qu'un titre qu'une question soit à
l'origine même d'un projet d'écriture
vous la posez combien de fois par jour
cette question je ne sais pas tout le
temps et de plus en plus j'ai une
relation et depuis longtemps je me la
suis encore plus posée après mon premier
livre et après la mort de mon frère
parce que je me disais comment font les
gens pour être heureux quand même et je
trouvais que ça ça méritait d'être posé
mais je me souviens que vous leur
enfouez aussi dans ce personnage d'Anna
oui bien sûr bien sûr parce que comme
vous le disiez c'est vraiment un livre
sur le temps le temps qu'on a pas c'est
la lutte contre le temps je trouve que
vieillir c'était aussi un sujet qui
méritait qu'on s'y attache pour des
femmes c'est un sujet ils ont vraiment
le droit c'est une des questions du
lycée un livre sur une génération et sur
les ponts entre les générations vous
parlez très très bien de ces 59 parce
que votre personnage d'abord c'est très
drôle il y a un peu de mélancolie aussi
mais il y a beaucoup d'humour votre
personnage elle est coincée entre deux
générations entre les féministes
historiques et entre les féministes du
néo féministe un peu walkistradical vous
trouvez qu'elle a été maltraité cette
génération des cinquantenaires je trouve
souvent que cette génération est accusée
d'être un peu le ventre mou du féminisme
moi parfois on me disait ça ce qui
m'énervait beaucoup parce que d'abord
j'avais l'impression que cette
génération là c'était battue notamment
pour le droit au travail
pour pour le droit justement d'avoir les
mêmes salaires que les hommes pour les
droits d'avoir des responsabilités plus
importantes donc déjà ça c'était pas
rien mais surtout j'avais l'impression
que cette génération là c'était la
première qui avait expérimenté
quotidien toutes les libertés acquises
mais des libertés acquises de manière
très nouvelle et donc finalement on
n'avait pas le droit de se plaindre en
fait à force de rester poli à forcement
considéré que rien n'est grave que cette
génération a un peu tout eu la liberté
l'avortement la possibilité de divorcer
de se remarier de faire des enfants plus
tard et d'avoir une belle carrière et
ben finalement elle a jamais apprise
je pense que c'est une génération
où on se disait souvent c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave ça va passer on est
peut-être la génération c'est pas grave
ça va passer et moi je suis extrêmement
reconnaissante
auprès envers la génération de très
jeunes filles qui disait rien ne va se
passer
dorénavant de la même manière qu'avant
on laissera plus rien passer d'ailleurs
c'est drôle parce que Anna elle a trois
filles et il y a énormément d'écart
entre la première et ces deux autres
filles et il y a beaucoup de discussions
avec l'aîné et à la fois elle trouve un
peu sa fille né au féministe un peu un
peu un peu radical parfois mais aussi
elle l'admire oui elle admire justement
justement
parce que des parties de cette
génération qui a demandé très gentiment
les choses s'il vous plaît ce qu'on
pourrait avoir les mêmes salaires que
les hommes bon bah force est de
constater que ça n'a pas tellement
marché et cette génération là elle est
beaucoup plus radicale beaucoup plus
engagée et c'est vrai que moi j'ai de la
gratitude je me suis un très bien d'une
chose qui m'est très très concrète un
jour j'ai intervé Pénélope bagio que
j'aime beaucoup l'auteur des culottées
qui est donc la génération suivante et
elle m'a parlé d'une chose qui lui est
arrivé dans le métro et elle employait
ce terme de micro-agression que je dois
reconnaître je n'avais jamais entendu et
j'ai eu une sorte de petite ligne dans
ma tête je me suis dit ah c'était donc
ça et tout ce qui nous est arrivé à nous
et je me souviens avec des amis ça nous
est arrivé les mains baladeuses tout et
des choses bien plus désagréables encore
et on se rassurait toujours en se disant
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave et ben
en fait si c'est vachement grave c'est
vachement grave et en même temps c'est
une une génération qui peut rire de la
gravité parce que c'est très drôle c'est
aussi léger que parfois un peu un peu
mélancolique alors Anna dites-nous qui
elle est exactement bah c'est une femme
vraiment de son temps et qui se retrouve
effectivement coincé entre deux
générations puisque avant c'était assez
simple en fait vous aviez vos enfants à
ces jeunes donc à 50 ans la vie de mère
était presque faite même si on est mère
toute la vie
mais là effectivement si vous avez eu
vos enfants assez tard si vos enfants
sont un tout petit peu Tanguy si on
rajoute à ça les conditions économiques
d'aujourd'hui qui font que les enfants
effectivement restent tard une mère qui
vieillit et vous vous retrouvez à
devenir en fait la mère de votre propre
mère tout en étant toujours la mère de
vos grands souvent donc ça fait
effectivement beaucoup de choses à faire
dans une journée ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que c'est un roman sur
l'époque c'est un roman sur le monde le
monde à la fois intérieur d'un âme et le
monde extérieur qui devient presque un
supportable avec les réseaux sociaux
tous les jours la guerre en Ukraine les
talibans Charlie Hebdo les attentats
l'urgence climatique on en parlait c'est
comment font les gens aussi malgré les
malheurs du monde exactement parce que
il me semble qu'avant en tous les cas
quand j'étais plus jeune et même petite
vous avez cette grande messe du JT le
soir
d'ailleurs on pouvait très bien en
éloigner les les enfants aujourd'hui les
fracas du monde ils sont partout ils
sont sur sur nos téléphones toute la
journée et c'est vrai que que ça arrive
dans la vie vous êtes heureux vous êtes
privilégié puis de bling et tout d'un
coup vous avez les migrants qui se noie
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et je trouve aussi
que une des vraies questions c'est
comment est-ce qu'on protège les enfants
ça ce qu'on peut pas les protéger des
malheurs du monde mais le protège les
enfants des écrans voilà alors ça c'est
vrai il y a aussi la question de la
pression de l'école parce que ça ça
aussi changé et d'avoir des enfants avec
autant des cas on voit l'évolution du
système scolaire où on demande quasiment
trop aux parents qui reçoivent en
permanence via les applications Pronote
ou autre les notes des enfants mais oui
mais c'est vrai que parents d'élèves
c'est devenu presque une profession moi
effectivement j'ai 20 ans d'écart entre
mes deux enfants je n'ai pas de fille
mais j'ai des fils et je n'ai jamais
regardé le le cahier de texte de mon
fils était et là j'ai quasiment des
alertes pour vous donner non seulement
les notes de vos enfants mais les notes
de toute la classe donc je trouve que
cette
terrible et je trouve aussi que il y a
trop de poids sur les épaules des mers
tant qu'on demandera d'ailleurs à toutes
les femmes dans n'importe quel interview
comment est-ce que vous faites pour
concilier votre rôle de mère et votre
rôle de femme tant qu'on ne demandera
pas systématiquement à tous les hommes
dans n'importe quel interview comment
concilier vous vos votre rôle d'homme et
votre rôle de père mais c'est vrai que
que moi qui fait des interviews toute la
journée même naturellement je la pose
pas cette question et je trouve que oui
qu'on demande vraiment trop Homer et
c'est toujours voilà il faut vraiment le
dire c'est c'est linéaire il y a pas de
chapitre on la suit on s'essouffle on
rit beaucoup et c'est parfois entourée
aussi elle a beaucoup d'amis Ana elle
partage beaucoup un tout petit mot pour
terminer Olivia de Lamberterie sur la
littérature allez éditrice Anna et c'est
très important vous êtes critique
littéraire vous-même vous la voyez
évoluer cette littérature les livres
Anna n'aime pas trop tout ces livres sur
les développements personnels tous ces
auteurs qui deviennent scénaristes pour
Netflix est-ce qu'elle est en danger la
littérature
en tous les cas je voulais la défendre
je pense qu'elle est un peu en danger
quand même la France et ce drôle de pays
où tout le monde veut écrire mais de
moins en moins de gens veulent lire donc
je toute la journée je reçois des mails
d'auto-édition des ateliers pour
apprendre à écrire moi j'aimerais qu'on
apprenne aux gens à lire même aux
adultes d'ailleurs et je trouve que les
critiques littéraires on a un vrai rôle
il y a une production énorme donc de
dire allez-y ça vous allez être heureux
et vous allez voir après vous regarderez
plus le monde de la même façon je vous
invite vraiment à lire comment font les
gens apparemment il y a beaucoup d'Anna
qui vous contactent c'est ça me disent
ah non c'est moi il y a plein d'hommes
des hommes aussi preuve que sont en
train de devenir des mères comme les
autres voilà et que les époques changent
roman d'une génération trop souvent
maltraités romant aussi qui rassemble
les générations merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci Olivia de Lamberterie
c'est à lire chez Stock vous allez
rester avec moi deux minutes parce on va
accueillir nos affranchis à présent pour
leur partie prix comme chaque comme
chaque soir alors Marco pommier va nous
raconter d'abord le show de Gérald
Darmanin hier soir dans l'hémicycle vous
allez voir c'est peut-être un numéro de
diététiste avec son collègue insoumis
Hugo bernalicis le mot de la semaine de
la sémiologue Mariette darrigan elle a
choisi le mot climat COP 27 oblige et
puis Brita Sandberg du Spiegel va nous
dire comment vue d'Allemagne au regard
on regarde la polynamique autour de
l'accueil des migrants de l'Océane
Viking nos affranchis les voici bonsoir
à tous les trois Marco on va commencer
avec vous vous nous parlez de ce duo
surprenant inattendu Darmanin bernalicis
les passes d'armes entre les deux hommes
ont été nombreux cette semaine à
l'occasion de l'examen dans l'hémicycle
de la loop me comprenait loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur projet de loi
qui prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur sur cinq ans alors ce duo
bernalis Darmanin à qui aime faire le
show et un il ne sait pas constituer
cette semaine rappelez-vous lors des
dernières des élections législatives
Hugo bernalicis était déjà en
représentation en pleine campagne il
improvisait un clip de rat un clip de
rap pardon assez surprenant clip dans
lequel il s'imaginait premier flic de
France à la place de Gérald Darmanin
regardez
[Musique]
comme Hugo Abobo Darmanin à chaud Hugo a
bobo plus de contrôle aux faciès avec
Hugo Abobo alors à l'époque un ce clip
il avait autant amusé qu'interloqué y
compris chez les soutiens du gouvernel
ici il a un sens du rythme on pourrait
dire que sa philosophie dit c'est un peu
de faire les choses sérieusement sans se
prendre au sérieux comme dirait Edouard
Philippe Hugo Bernal 6 il s'est
spécialisé dans les questions de police
justice à la France insoumise alors
pourquoi je vous fais écouter un peu de
rap Myriam ce soir et bien tout
simplement parce que cette semaine
Gérald Darmanin a fait allusion à ce
clip vidéo je vous pose le contexte
lundi les députés dans l'hémicycle
commence à examiner la locmi Hugo
bernalicis au nom de la France insoumise
défend une motion de rejet préalable du
texte réponse du ministre de l'Intérieur
sur le ton de l'ironie bien sûr
monsieur Bernal ici je vous avoue que je
vous reconnais pas
je sais pas ce qui vous arrive
je vous ai senti même un peu frustré
finalement Hugo n'était pas à Bobo Hugo
est dans l'opposition
il s'amuse Gérald Darmanin il a trouvé
un sparring partner idéal c'est ça oui
Myriam alors bon français sparring
partner ça désigne un partenaire d'un
certain niveau destiné à faire de
l'opposition un athlète lors de la
préparation d'un match vous voyez pour
la définition exacte est-ce que vous
comprenez où je veux en venir elle
l'athlète c'est donc Gérald Darmanin et
selon les rumeurs il prépare un match la
présidentielle de 2027 Hugo bernalicis
taquin en a bien conscience écoutez
j'ai voulu dire qu'il y avait un
ministre assez brillant pour obtenir 15
milliards d'euros mais pas trop quand
même pour ne pas trop savoir comment les
dépenser puisque cette question il se
les poser après peut-être un plan de
carrière 2027 étant dans le viseur et ce
qui est ce qui est tout à votre honneur
monsieur le ministre alors géraldar
maintenant pense-t-il à l'Élysée en se
rasant officiellement la question se
pose pas pour l'instant avant l'heure
c'est pas l'heure disait-il cet été et
puis Myriam le vrai adversaire de Gérald
Darmanin c'est pas Hugo bernalissi c'est
surtout Bruno Le Maire voir Édouard
Philippe dozo deux autres grands fauves
de la majorité qui préparent leurs pions
pour 2027 Darmanin qui n'a pas eu besoin
de 49,3 pour faire passer son budget
enfin son texte à lui et je crois qu'il
fallait pas échappé merci beaucoup Marco
Mariette le mot de la semaine cop27 elle
s'achève aujourd'hui à sharm-el-sheik en
égyptée c'est le climat vous vouliez
nous nous parler de ce terme en
chaussant vos lunettes de sémiologue
comme chaque semaine
alors mes lunettes et mes presque aussi
ma longue vue mon télescope parce qu'en
fait le terme climat veut dire voûte
vous de céleste au départ c'est sur un
verbe clean en grec s'incliner c'est à
dire c'est ce qui s'incline au dessus de
nous et qui nous protège aussi donc
c'est ça que ça veut dire au départ et
pour quelque chose nous protège on a
peur pour cette chose finalement donc on
scrute depuis l'Antiquité ou voir depuis
la nuit des temps est-ce qu'il y a pas
un petit trou quelque part dans la
couche d'ozone ou est-ce que les dieux
ou le ciel ne vont pas nous tomber sur
la tête comme dans Astérix alors là on
commence à angoisser donc la peur du
changement climatique est très ancienne
elle est très très ancienne elle est
depuis la nuit des temps alors c'est
tout à fait intéressant quand les
historiens se penchent sur cette
climatologie on voit qu'il y a des pics
en quelque sorte au moment politique
alors au moment de la Révolution il y a
déjà une accusation alors c'est à
l'aristocratie mais de déforester de
déboiser il y a aussi des discussions
sur les eaux stagnantes c'est-à-dire le
les nobles qui faisaient des étangs
artificiels locropisme ça rendait les
gens du couple malade donc on a déjà
cette question politique et ce miroir
très très important entre le macrocosme
le monde notre environnement et
nous-mêmes le microcosme que chaque
corps humain est si vous voulez vous
dire un mot Surmont est-ce que alors
Montesquieu bah il avait effectivement
pensé déjà tout ça avec sa théorie des
climats et donc il avait bien pointé
qu'il y avait une une correspondance
entre le ciel en quelque sorte lequel
les les peuples se trouvaient et leur
propre identité donc c'est une question
longtemps que il y a une forme de
parallèle entre la question du climat et
la question du climat mental aussi
exactement chacun nous a un climat
personnel alors on le voit bien quand il
voulait quand on dit bah le climat est
tendu dans une réunion ou dans une
entreprise sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale très souvent ben on parle de
climat délétère on a parlé tout à
l'heure des enfants hier vous avez parlé
de l'écho anxiété c'est tout à fait
cette dynamique analogique est-ce que
c'est votre esprit imaginaire l'analogie
donc quand un enfant pense que la
planète est blessée c'est lui-même qu'il
sent comme blessé donc c'est là-dessus
que je voulais c'est pour ça que je
voulais parler de ce mot aujourd'hui il
y a plein d'autres choses à dire mais je
crois qu'il faut déjà pointer que nous
devons faire attention à la dégradation
du climat mais pas que mais au sens
météo si vous voulez être propre de
notre propre psychologie et de la
psychologie de notre pays parce que nous
avons tous appris que la France était un
climat bien tempéré alors il y a le
réchauffement donc ça ça pose une
question mais sur le plan symbolique je
crois qu'il faut être attentif à ça et
pour finir le mot clean dont je vous
parlais au départ en fait il a il a deux
séries de mots des mots très positifs et
des mots très négatifs si je prends
inclinaison j'ai une inclinaison pour
tel sujet ou telle personne tout d'un
coup une belle histoire peut arriver
mais il y a aussi sur le la même racine
le déclin donc attention à l'équilibre
ça vous parle je trouve ça très
intéressant de savoir que depuis des
siècles on a déjà cette anxiété qui
serait intéressante c'est de savoir
comment on y répondait d'ailleurs
à cette anxiété concernant le climat et
vos enfants vous même vous êtes touchés
sont enfin je trouve qu'ils sont géniaux
pour nous ramener tout le temps
à nous après il faudrait qu'on change
nos réflexes ça m'amuse toujours de voir
qu'à la météo on trouve toujours
finalement que c'est pas bien qui pleuve
alors qu'on devrait dire génial
aujourd'hui il pleut là on aura un peu
et arrêter de se réjouir quand l'hiver
est trop clément et trop doux c'est vrai
que vous êtes la correspondante à Paris
du spiggle vous voulez nous nous parler
au fond de cette crise de cette crise de
la chaîne Viking mais vu d'Allemagne
voilà puisque cette discussion autour de
ce bateau de l'ONG a suscité ces
jours-ci un débat d'une grande violence
en France comme en Italie et discussions
politiques extrêmement tendue et les
Allemands regardent ça avec un certain
étonnement pour ne pas dire parfois ils
sont vraiment perplexes de suivre ça
quand Marine Le Pen dit par exemple
qu'au lieu de combattre l'immigration
clandestine Emmanuel Macron de
l'organise écrin la création d'un
lampadouza Français que quand les
anciens socialistes avertissent que s'il
n'y a pas maintenant une ligne ferme Le
Pen passera la prochaine fois élection
ou que les républicains parlent une
faute lourde et qu'Emmanuel Macron a
ouvert la boîte de Pandore en décidant
de laisser accoster le hochine à Toulon
alors vous êtes tellement de vous êtes
venus avec quelques chiffres voilà
puisque les Allemands aiment bien sortir
les chiffres pour mettre les choses en
place tout d'abord seulement 10% des
migrants arrivent sur des bateaux des
ONG en Italie donc pendant à côté c'est
10% il y a 90% des migrants qui arrivent
avec des petits bateaux et qui sont pris
en charge par les Italiens sans
hésitation ensuite sur le 234 personnes
abordent au schönb King il y avait 44
bébés enfants ou tout le monde est plus
ou moins d'accord je suppose qu'il
fallait les accueillir et les sauver
quant aux autres on sait aujourd'hui que
123 personnes vont être renvoyées dans
leur pays d'origine dès que leur état de
santé le permet reste alors environ une
soixantaine de migrants dans le monde
politique et c'est maintenant de faire
un cas de principe et pour reprendre
d'autres chiffres et pour comparer les
stations en Allemagne en 2022 plus de
180 000 migrants ont posé une demande
d'asile chez nous et si ajoute le nombre
de plus de 1 million de réfugiés
Ukrainiens que l'Allemagne accueillie
cette année dans dans une procédure
accélérée à la France beaucoup plus bah
la France aurait su un peu plus que
100.000 200 Ukrainiens pendant la même
période les chiffres du démon d'asile
les derniers chiffres disponibles date
de 2021 c'était 103000 donc c'est
vraiment beaucoup moins et je ne
voudrais pas être mal comprise
l'immigration n'est pas un concours mais
si on regarde bien le nombre de
personnes accueillies en Allemagne cette
année correspond à peu près à celui de
15 2016 lors de la guerre en Syrie
pourtant en Allemagne aussi la question
migratoire crée des débats et des
polémiques non non c'est pas sans
discussion mais c'est discussions sont
pas de la même violence mais il y a bien
des villes comme des communes qui disent
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus qu'ils arrivent
à la limite de leur capacités qu'ils ont
établi des centres d'accueil mais que
maintenant ils en peuvent plus mais
c'est pas le même débat qu'en France et
je crois que cette histoire de l'oshin
Viking on dit quelque chose de l'état de
la démocratie en France et la grande
question pour moi c'est pourquoi 200
migrants à cause de Toulon sont capables
de provoquer une telle excitation
politique mais je vous laisse le soin de
trouver les réponses à ces questions
vous-même et ben merci et merci du
fardeau
merci Britta sanberg ça fait du bien de
regarder un petit peu d'ailleurs
passionnant parce que ça permet de
remettre je trouve les choses dans leur
juste valeur et vos dernières questions
et tout à fait pertinentes impertinente
et pertinente bah écoutez merci beaucoup
en tout cas voilà on a participé déjà
entre le climat la question des migrants
la vie d'Anna la charge mentale c'est un
peu le roman de la charge mentale d'une
certaine manière que vous signez de
Lamberterie les enfants sont d'ailleurs
aussi très très sensibles à ces sujets
je trouve pas seulement mais lorsqu'il
voit des enfants comme eux je pense
qu'ils ont des réponses qui sont très
intéressantes et d'ailleurs je
réveillais peut-être parfois l'humanité
de l'enfant qui était en nous peut-être
la solution merci merci les affranchis
c'est le week-end profitez bien on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine d'ici là
très belle soirée bien sûr
[Musique]